hey guys it is the 15th of January today
my name is Jess McDonald and you
watching games what news Naughty Dog
have said they're doing their best to
shoot for uncharted 4 at 60 frames per
second but they won't compromise the
overall experience game director Bruce
Straley have said that they locked the
frame rate at 30 frames per second for
the demo shown at the PlayStation
experience even though the game is now
achieving a higher frame rate speaking
to edge magazine straightly said we're
going to do whatever it takes to make
the game we want to make if it means we
could go for 60 but lose something that
would really impact the planes
experience then it's our choice as
developers to say well we're going to go
for the experience instead of the 60
frames voxels to is about to get a
massive patch ahead of the scholar of
the first game of rerelease the update
focuses on upgrading world events and
matchmaking on top of that there's also
the introduction of a new character the
scholar of the first sin the update
seems to be adding a lot of features
we're expecting in the scholar the
person re-release which will bundle up
dark souls 2 and all of its DLC for xbox
one ps4 and PC platforms the part will
be available for free on februari 5 and
you can check out the full patch notes
for yourself on the game spot finally
hotline Miami 2 has been banned in
australia of the inclusion of a
controversial spain the game has been
refused classification by the Australian
Classification Board who claimed gains
that in their words depict Express or
otherwise deal with matters of sex drug
misuse or addictions crime cruelty
violence or revolting or abhorrent
phenomena in such a way that they offend
against the standards of morality
decency and propriety generally accepted
fight reasonable adults to the extent
that they should not be classified
developer devolver digital responded to
the band saying they believe the ACB has
stretched the facts in their assessment
of the game
controversial elements in particular the
scene depicting sexual violence which
resulted in the band I won't describe it
here but if you want to know more about
the band all the scene in question you
can check out our story on gamespot let
me know down in the comments if you
reckon the hotline Miami to ban is
justified you can head to gain spot for
more news stories on things like the
Simpsons in Minecraft and why the US
isn't getting the new smaller 3ds those
are all the things that I have for you
today but be sure to check back same
time tomorrow for my top five stories of
the whole gaming week I will see you
then